[Music]
putting kids in a costume can turn out
to be one of the most hilarious things
to do when your apparent sushi burrito
and Pablo Escobar are all popular
choices but wait until you see the kids
that managed to pull off the Pennywise
clown from it don't forget to subscribe
to our Channel and give this video a big
thumbs up now let's check out 10 of the
best kids costumes ever Pablo Escobar
get ready to laugh because Pablo Escobar
look-alikes are our new favorite
costumes
although Pablo Escobar wasn't exactly an
admirable person especially not for a
child his look sure makes him look like
an excellent choice for kids costume
here are some of our absolute favorite
Pablo Escobar looks if you need a good
laugh check out these kids with
mustaches
check out this cutie looking like a
spitting image of the popular kingpin
except well we hope he's not doing
anything that would get him in trouble
here's another one for you this little
man definitely looks like he's ready to
do some business Pablo Escobar Halloween
costumes have actually sparked a debate
whether or not they're appropriate for
little ones many claim that it's
inappropriate to dress your children
looking like career criminals but then
again you have to admit that seeing a
child with a mustache is one of the most
hilarious things ever how could you not
laugh when you see this mustache face
carrying a briefcase looking like he's
ready for business
this kid absolutely has to win the Pablo
Escobar costume award but he's not the
only one he definitely has some
competition because this father/daughter
duo is just as amazing what do you think
is this appropriate or should they just
stick with adorable mustaches and ditch
the Escobar resemblance
Aladdin's monkey Disney costumes never
go out of style we've seen plenty of
Elsa's mallanna's and similar Disney
Princesses but there are a few Disney
costumes that are totally cuter looking
kids and monkey costumes are
automatically the cutest things you've
ever seen but kids in Aladdin's monkey
costumes are just hilarious from the
entire Aladdin family complete with the
Cutie in a monkey costume to these
adorable kids these babies are
definitely rocking the Aladdin look the
tail the ears the Fez everything's
absolutely perfect we can't decide which
one is the cutest but they all
definitely deserve an award for melting
our hearts one of our favorite costumes
are the ones
the entire family participates and these
Disney families are definitely taking
the cake we have to admit that this is a
perfect Halloween inspiration why use a
toy monkey when you can just dress your
child up in an adorable costume and win
all cute points available we can't get
over the ears and the confused look of
this little guy he's absolutely perfect
come to think of it a boo is probably
one of those gibberish words most of
these kids are able to say so dressing
them up in a booze costume is definitely
fitting we hope you can handle all this
cuteness today because we're definitely
not done yet
Cruella De Vil Disney costumes are
always a popular choice during Halloween
but we love it when kids want to portray
someone else other than your typical
Disney Princesses while there's honestly
nothing to admire about Cruella Deville
you have to admit that her style is out
of this world now imagine the style on a
child big fur coat half black half white
hair and tons of karela de Vil related
bling it turns out dressing up as karela
is absolutely hilarious
check out these kids they really managed
to pull off the 101 Dalmatians villain
and added their own spunk to the look we
can't decide which one we prefer the
cutie in an oversized coat with an
actual Dalmatian costume or it's the non
impressed kid with jewelry that's almost
as long as she is from kids to teens the
miss de Vil look never gets old to
recreate her look grab an animal print
coat the bigger the better then be on
the lookout for a half-black half-white
wig add a black dress red gloves red
shoes and her signature stick and you're
done you'll get extra bonus points if
you can dress other kids in a Dalmatian
costume like these two cuties even
though Cruella herself isn't exactly
admirable there's just something about
her clothes that makes her the perfect
Halloween character burrito if you
thought there's no way these costumes
could get any cuter brace yourself
because things are about to get totally
adorable we've all seen babies wrapped
in cozy blankets that make them look
like animals but nothing has prepared us
for babies in a burrito costume you can
actually get your baby a costume of a
wrap with lettuce tomatoes and other
vegetables of course they're not real
and are totally safe for babies but if
you're a bored parent and need to make
things in your life just a little bit
funnier you can get creative and make
your very own Halloween baby burrito
check out this kid wrapped in tinfoil
with actual burrito ingredients on each
side doesn't his hat look like a
tortilla and here are a few more for you
because this is honestly the best way to
dress up your infant we also can't stop
laughing at this crawling cutie in a
taco costume it's true what they say
when you become a parent your creativity
reaches a new level seriously these are
some of the best costumes we have ever
seen we bet this will once and for all
settle the taco versus burrito debate
because all of these costumes are just
too adorable for words we love a bit of
baby humour and these baby burritos are
definitely delivering pumpkin if you
spend a lot of time on the Internet
you've probably seen at least a dozen
kids in pumpkin Halloween costumes well
here's another dozen because we just
can't get enough of the cuteness from
real pumpkins to actual pumpkin costumes
get ready because your hearts are going
to melt over this cuteness we're not
sure what it is with babies and pumpkins
but pumpkins just make them a hundred
times cuter we can't decide which one we
like best the baby in the actual pumpkin
or these cuties and their adorable
costumes the smaller the baby the cuter
they'll look in the pumpkin costume
check out these little guys with their
adorable pumpkin hats it looks like
these babies can pull off practically
any look although it seems like it would
probably be much more difficult for a
toddler to even attempt to walk around
in an actual pumpkin we were serious
when we said that these are some of the
best kids costumes ever if you have a
small child their next Halloween costume
is now probably sorted either go to the
store and buy a pumpkin costume or just
pick your own straight from the patch
remember they're not just for carving
they also make some of the cutest
Halloween costumes ever wonder woman out
of all inspiring female characters out
there you have to admit that Wonder
Woman is the one that should be seen by
more kids what's not to admire about a
character that's strong loyal and
incredibly inspiring we love Disney
Princesses
but Halloween costumes shouldn't be
limited to just Disney Wonder Woman
costumes never get old and these cuties
have recreated the look in the best
possible way we can't decide which one's
the cutest so here are all of them in no
particular order we love the added
sparkles fabulous tutus the gold
headband and other accessories that make
Wonder Woman one of the most
recognizable female superheroes ever and
it's even better when
parents get involved this dad dressed up
as a different character every single
day and waved his kids goodbye as they
went to school but we think these kids
still beat him at the best Wonder Woman
costume ever you can easily recreate
this look yourself just grab red and
blue clothes and gold colored
accessories learn a few superhero moves
and you'll be good to go
bonus points if you can pull off Wonder
Woman's iconic red and white boots these
kids really do look like they're ready
to save the world and they really
deserve to have all of the Halloween
candy we have Edward Scissorhands
costumes aren't always cute especially
not on Halloween some kids go above and
beyond to create some of the scariest
costumes ever and we have to say they
can definitely pull them off one of the
characters you'd never ever want to see
in real life is Edward Scissorhands
seeing someone with scissors instead of
their hands is definitely scary but
imagine them being a small person that's
just running around on Halloween
although scary these are some of the
best kids costumes ever check them out
along with having incredibly scary hands
and an awesome outfit some of these kids
also have very realistic makeup and
totally cool hair the best part about
this costume is that you can basically
recreate this look from things you
already own just grab a couple of
kid-friendly utensils the darkest outfit
they own add a few belts and find a dark
wig with messy hair and you'll be good
to go as a bonus point grab white face
paint and a bit of eyeliner for that
truly horrifying look and if you think
that toddlers dressed as Edward
Scissorhands can be scary wait until you
see these kiddos pulling off the most
adorable but yet scary look just make
sure they don't run around with scissors
because that never turns out to be a
good idea
sushi we're not done yet do you prefer
seeing kids in cute costumes or do you
like the scary ones well get ready
because nothing will prepare you for
this cuteness kids in the sushi costume
are now a thing and we never knew it was
something we needed in our lives until
we saw this get ready because the
smaller the kid the more adorable the
sushi outfit like this cutie with salmon
on his back or this little girl inside
an actual sushi costume check out the
detail it even has an avocado inside we
love the added hat that just make these
costumes even more adorable seriously
these kids are completely adorable
we love the sushi rolls but we're
so impressed by this actual sushi roll
outfit this is definitely one of those
costumes only kids can pull off but they
can really make this one of the best
costumes ever you can actually find some
of these sushi outfits on Etsy and they
come complete with lettuce detail and
even seaweed if you haven't dressed your
kid up in this Japanese dish it's time
to do so
then make sure to send us a picture
because this is the one costume we can
never get enough of will always prefer
the cute heart-melting costumes over the
scary ones especially if their food
costumes the Jersey Shore cast Jersey
Shore was one of the most popular
reality TV series that started back in
2009 and aired until 2012 the
controversial show that often made
headlines featured a cast with big
personalities and even bigger party
habits
Snooki Sammi JWoww the situation Ronnie
Vinny and Pauly D made us laugh and
became even bigger stars once the show
is over this viral image proves that the
show also has kid fans and it sparked
some controversy over kids wanting to
dress as the characters that represented
an inappropriate lifestyle but putting
all that aside you have to admit that
these kids are really pulling off the
ultimate Jersey Shore cast in the best
way possible can you recognize them all
from left to right we see Pauly D JWoww
the situation Sammi Snooki and Ronnie on
the left and they seem to look like
these kids are actual friends in real
life while some of the cast now have
their own kids that look exactly like
them we're pretty sure these children
are a spitting image of the infamous
Jersey Shore crew our favorite has to be
sneaky however the situation's look is
pretty much spot-on along with Pauly D's
and Ronnie's would you ever let your
child dress as a controversial reality
TV star for Halloween or would you pick
a slightly more appropriate and
inspiring costume Pennywise clown from
it we've seen a lot of adorable costumes
in this video but let's check out one of
the scariest costumes ever warning if
you're not a fan of scary clowns skip
this part of the video the clown
phenomenon has scared many people in the
past few years and one of the reasons is
Stephen King's novel it the book
recently got a big-screen feature and it
definitely doesn't help with the clown
fear here are some kids that really
managed to pull off the Pennywise clown
costume and made it a million
I'm scarier it's definitely not a pretty
sight seeing a kid clown with white face
paint and a couple of balloons standing
in the middle of the street
there's just something about clowns that
scares a lot of people and there's
actually a real psychological reason
behind the fear some might find clown
children cute but clowns have been
associated with fear ever since the
medieval times these kids are definitely
doing the job of putting the fear into
the infamous clown from it to recreate
this look just grab a clown mask get a
white face paint a red nose and make it
as creepy as possible add a clown outfit
and a few balloons and you're all done
to look like penny wise just mimic the
face paint and you'll be ready to have
one of the best costumes ever
can you beat these awesome kids though
that's it for 10 best kids costumes ever
for more videos like this one check out
15 who wore it better pics that will
make you laugh out loud see you next
time
[Music]